Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie.
Todd Phillips posted a brand new scene
from Joker two.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch Easter eggs.
Obviously, it's a big deal
because they're introducing
another version of Harley
Quinn that's played by Lady Gaga,
not Margot Robbie.
And it sounds like Margot
Robbie is going to survive the DC reboot
and James Gunn's new plan for DC movies.
Also, explain
how this movie fits into that new plan,
because these are all the new DC movies
that are coming,
but they will have elseworlds movies
like movies that are specifically
classified as Elseworlds.
But you may have seen in your feeds
because it is Valentine's Day in real life
as I'm posting this video.
Todd Phillips also celebrated
Valentine's Day by posting the first
look at Harley Quinn meeting Joker, and
he's actually in his classic clown makeup.
His caption
just read Happy Valentine's Day.
And in the scene, you can see Harley
Quinn is just captivated with Joker
like she can't believe what's going on.
She's so excited.
She's just so taken with it all.
She seems hypnotized by him,
which is kind of their dynamic
in the comics and in a lot of the movies.
Obviously in the DCU since that Birds of
Prey movie, they move slightly past it.
Like Margot.
Robbie's Harley Quinn
isn't enraptured with the Joker
as she once was in their relationship in
the comics goes back and forth like it's
meant to be the worst, most toxic
relationship you could possibly imagine.
They even covered that arc on Batman,
the animated series, with her
leaving the Joker for a little while
and just going to have fun with Poison
Ivy and briefly
trying to turn good in the picture.
It looks like she's just kissed him
like she's kissed him
because he's kind of flabbergasted
by it, like, hey, this is pretty cool.
And she's got his clown
makeup smudged on her lips,
which is usually the opposite way
these things go.
Usually it's the girl
who smudges her makeup on the dude.
But because we're talking
about the Joker here
who wears clown makeup, he wears
way more makeup than Harley Quinn,
even though she eventually does
wear a version of that makeup to it.
It seems like at this stage
in their relationship,
she hasn't got to that point yet.
But you do notice they are both in plain
clothes, which means she may have
already helped him escape Arkham Asylum,
allowing them to actually change clothes.
And for him to actually be able
to put the makeup back on,
unless this is also part
of one of Arthur's hallucinations,
since he is meant to be
an unreliable narrator.
Good example of
that is at the end of the first movie
when they revealed his whole relationship
arc with his neighbor
was something that happened in his head.
He just imagine the whole thing.
She just walked in one night and found him
sitting in her living room like, Please
don't kill me or my child.
Strange person in a lot of the movie
was supposed to take place in Arkham
Asylum because the whole idea is that
they're introducing Harley Quinn as Dr.
Harleen Quinzel
and she slowly becomes the Harley
Quinn character,
you know, from the comics.
She started out as a doctor in Arkham
Asylum and then slowly fell in love
with him and just sort of taken
with his whole psychology.
Todd Phillips
also posted the first scene of the movie
or the first scene that they filmed.
It might not chronologically
be the first scene in the actual movie.
This is the first scene with Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker character getting a shave.
Notice his trademark emaciated
look like he gained a lot of weight
after they filmed the first movie
because he lost so much weight
like a crazy amount of weight.
It was meant to play
into the sort of unhealthy
vibe of the character,
like he was just living
a very unhealthy lifestyle
because of everything
that had been happening to him
and everything he'd been going through.
Clearly, things have not gotten better
with him being inside Arkham Asylum.
He looks none the worse for where
he's still inside Arkham Asylum.
If you couldn't tell
while he's being shaved here.
This is a prison guard doing
the actual shaving, holding his head down,
just in case he tries to escape
while they're actually holding
a sharp razor to his neck.
The way that James Gunn
and the other Warner Brothers
people talked about the movie,
they aren't planning on touching
what Todd Phillips is doing
with the Joker movie at all.
It's still going to be in its own
alternate universe.
I think that's
just because the first movie did so well.
Had it not been so successful,
they probably would have soft rebooted
that too.
They're getting the same treatment
that Matt Reeves
is getting with his Batman
franchise, Robert Pattinson's Batman,
all those spinoffs.
Those are also being currently treated
like its own alternate continuity.
The title is pronounced Joker Foil a do in
it's French for Joker Shared madness
as in Joker shared psychotic
episode is a term in psychology
used to describe when multiple people
share the same delusion,
the same psychotic episode.
This also confirms
now that the title Shared Delusion, so
to speak, refers to the shared delusion
the Joker will share with Dr.
Harley Quinn during his
stay at Arkham Asylum.
There are a lot of reports that say
that most of the movie will take place in
and around Arkham Asylum,
so it'll deal with the development
of their relationship,
like how he meets her for the first time,
how she eventually falls in love with him,
and eventually
he winds up twisting her to the dark side,
so to speak.
They've kind of addressed that
in previous Batman projects,
like they did a little bit
during the previous
Suicide Squad movies with the Margot
Robbie version of Harley Quinn.
We saw a little bit of her origin story
as Harley Quinn.
It sounds like a lot of this
movie is just going to be
a much bigger version of that also,
because it's still going
to be relatively low budget,
It makes sense that they would keep
a lot of it in and around Arkham Asylum.
It'll be really interesting to see
what she looks like compared to the Margot
Robbie version of Harley Quinn.
I had to cut out a little bit of the music
from the teaser trailer
just for copyright reasons,
but this is what the actual audio
sounds like on it.
It's playing that classic song
Cheek to Cheek,
which is just meant to reference
the context of their relationship.
Like this is happening in Arkham Asylum.
Like it's a reference to the fantasy
that is taking place in his head.
You're never quite sure
if what's happening is really happening
or if it's just happening inside his head.
And now, obviously, because it's a shared
delusion, is it happening inside her head
as well?
The fun fact about the Joker
serum, too, is that it's actually derived
from the scarecrow fear toxin.
But we haven't had the scarecrow inside
the Joaquin Phenix Joker universe yet.
And even though it is possible
that he could use
some version of the Joker
serum during this Joker sequel,
I don't think they're going to play it
that way.
I think they'll keep it
in the realm of metaphor.
When he talks about sharing his madness
with everyone, like through his actions,
through the media, people will watch it
like the people who are writing it.
It'll just get crazier
and crazier and crazier.
And he'll start to win them
over through his actions and they will
then begin to share in his madness.
It's not like he's going to go around
dumping a bunch of fear toxin or joker
toxin into the water supply.
That's the really cool,
The really insidious thing
about the first Joker movie is that
he doesn't need any kind of joker toxin
like that.
It's all about the role of the media
in all this.
Like in the case of the first movie,
it was his broadcast
at the end that helped
push his exploits to a legendary status.
But at the time, he was already building
on an existing system of riots
that all the people in Gotham
had been upset about.
The current administration,
the growing problems in the city,
the whole inequality
between the common people who were rioting
in the ultra rich people represented
by Thomas Wayne, Bruce Wayne's family.
He was in the middle of running for mayor,
and there were
these escalating series of riots
throughout the movie as things got crazier
and crazier and crazier public outcries
during his appearances.
Eventually, before he went full Joker
at the end of the movie,
he called the crowd a bunch of clowns.
The whole thing, with him
secretly being Thomas Wayne's son,
I think was actually a bit of a misdirect.
But the way the movie plays it,
they want to be kind of ambiguous about it
because you're meant
to be viewing everything in the film
from Arthur's perspective.
So as he descends into madness,
you're meant to see things get crazier
and weirder and weirder.
In reality,
I think that his mother had suffered
from mental delusions
like he does in the movie,
like she had had mental episodes
when she was younger,
and she just fell in love with Thomas
Wayne
when her family was working at his mansion
and started to get creepy at his house.
And they just imply that his family
kind of pushed her family out
the door, like, okay, you go off
on your own, no more working for us.
And she just descended
into a form of madness
and just came up with this delusion
that she had been
in a relationship with Thomas Wayne
when that really wasn't the case.
So the idea is that he had played a party
clown and Thomas Wayne had called
the people like him, like the lower class
people, a bunch of clowns acting crazy.
He started to feel like
his life was a joke.
Eventually, he just kind of owns all that
by wearing the name as his own mantle,
calling himself the Joker.
Matt Reeves actually
had his version of the very shocking Joker
in the Batman movie.
Kind of say something similar, like, it's
not so bad being a clown.
The big difference during the Batman
movie, though, is the ages of the Batman.
The Joker in the Joker is in prison
in Arkham
Asylum because Batman put him there.
They released a deleted scene
that was meant to be on the one year
anniversary of him putting him in prison.
So the very shocking Joker
was joking about that with him
like, Isn't it our anniversary? He present
space.
And so if it wasn't clear now, obviously,
Matt Reeves has confirmed that the Joker
in his universe is not going to be
the Joaquin Phenix version of Joker.
And even though they are doing
all this crazy multiverse stuff
with the Flash movie, the Joaquin
Phenix Joker movie will still be set
in an alternate universe.
It's still going to be rated
R, it's still going to be part of DC's
Black Label, which is what they're using
for their darker, more hardcore films,
especially ones
that are set in alternate universes
that aren't necessarily connected
to all the big DCU stuff.
The original movie took place during 1981.
Joaquin Phenix is in his fifties
in present day in real world.
But he was playing a 3040 something joker.
So when he references to Batman
or any of the other preexisting
DC characters in the Joker
sequel is just meant to be a coincidence.
Or in the case of this version of Batman,
just a totally new,
different version of Batman.
So Bruce Wayne would still be a child
living with Alfred.
He'd be a little bit older,
but still be a child and there wouldn't be
a bunch of Batman stuff happening yet.
Like I said,
this is the list of every single DC movie
and TV series, this coming up
and where it fits into the canon
in the way that James Gunn said that
they're treating the Joker movie
in the Batman movie with Robert Pattinson
is they're meant to be complete elseworlds
projects outside of his DCU.
They're calling it the DCU now.
That means when they introduce
the new version of Batman in the DCU,
the older one who has Damian Wayne.
If they do the Joker
at some point in the DCU movies,
it'll be a completely different
joker again, not the Barry Keoghan one
and not the Joaquin Phenix one.
Let me know in the comments
Who do you want them to cast?
Is that version of The Joker?
Remember, because it's an older Batman,
it would also probably be a slightly older
version of Joker as well.
Willem Dafoe as the Joker would actually
be pretty bad as there were a whole bunch
of Super Bowl trailers, a couple different
flash trailers with different footage.
Click here for my trailer videos
for those, and click here
for my new Guardians of the Galaxy three
Super Bowl trailer, video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching, everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.